[Musik]
in steinfurt in mecklenburg vorpommern
gibt es bald schnelles internet mit
steuergeldern gefördert werde eine
breitband leitung quer durchs dorf
gelegt aber die steinfurter bürger haben
nichts von dieser brandneuen leitung
ihre häuser werden nämlich nicht ans
netz angeschlossen schnelles internet
bekommt lediglich die örtliche begräbnis
kapelle
wir kriegen also da kann man gar nicht
beschreiben was das für ein schwachsinn
eigentlich also ich kann es mir nicht
erklären ich empfinde das ist ein scherz
löschers also einmal im monat ist hier
schon gottesdienst im sommer weil es uns
ein bisschen zu kalt ist aber was ich
mit dem internet wollen das ist nur ein
bisschen schleierhaft
die breitband leitung zur kapelle wird
staatlich gefördert dabei abzweigungen
zu den häusern nicht denn das schnelle
internet fürs dorf soll ein privates
telekommunikationsunternehmen legen
dieser sogenannte eigenwirtschaftliche
ausbau hat gesetzlich vorrang aber den
will keine firma machen für die
unternehmen scheint es sich nicht zu
rechnen
die friedhofskapelle als ein
öffentliches gebäude wird angeschlossen
die privathäuser der bewohner bleiben in
der internet steinzeit hängen
der stellvertretende bürgermeister
matthias bartl schewski verzweifelt am
verwaltungssitz in ihren im kreis und es
gibt keinen
es lässt sich niemand packen und es
keiner verantwortlich und wir wissen
nicht wie wir das gehalt kriegen ja also
es fließt jetzt hier geld in den
pommerschen sand und wir machen uns hier
auch ein bisschen lächerlich ja weil es
ja eine absurde situation aber wie kann
es sein dass eine friedhofskapelle einen
internetanschluss bekommt die einzelnen
häuser bei leer ausgehen
auch im zuständigen landratsamt scheint
beim ratlos zu sein
schriftlich heißt es der
eigenwirtschaftliche ausbau sollte bis
zum 31 17 2018 beendet und in betrieb
genommen sein
es liegen die im landkreis vorpommern
greifswald keine informationen vor
was davon tatsächlich realisiert wurde
in steinfurt wurde nichts realisiert die
betroffenen sind stinksauer richtig
abhängt also wir fühlen uns hier als
leute dritter klasse muss man so sagen
auf dem land und das einzig schade drum
weil wir auch steuern auch zu zahlen
es ist einfach nicht zu glauben es
protest eine posse und die kapelle ist
im landkreis vorpommern-greifswald kein
einzelfall auch das drei kilometer
entfernte stillgelegte bahnhofsgebäude
soll ein glasfaseranschluss bekommen das
ding ist eine völlige ruine wahnsinn